robert habeck ist der beliebteste
politiker deutschlands das belegen
neueste umfragen und der grüne
vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister ist
so etwas wie der kaiser der umfragen
doch dieser kaiser ist bald nackt denn
was kommt denn wirklich bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern an außer
mahnende oder auch mal für verständnis
werben
der baute verlängerung der
akw-laufzeiten geht nicht aussetzen das
verbot für verbrenner ab 2035 geht nicht
wer gas umwandelt im strom soll dafür
bei strafen bezahlen ich finde wir haben
ein absolutes sondersituation und
deswegen müssen auch sonder maßnahmen
ergreifen akw laufzeiten verlängern mit
den brennstäben das kann mir keiner
erzählen dass wir die nicht weiter
bekommen das zweite ist eben jede form
von fossilen energien weiter nutzen für
diese übergangszeit steinkohle
braunkohle und vor allen dingen brauchen
wir eine positive vision für die zukunft
das wünsche ich mir von einem
vizekanzler der bald auch gerne
bundeskanzler werden will